je sais pas si vous saviez mais je suis
passionné des casse-têtes enfin
j'imagine que vous en doutiez il ya
quelques jours de seven m'a dit mais
pourquoi tu fais pas des vidéos de
résolution de casse tête sur sa chaîne
je suis ok pourquoi pas on peut essayer
ça donc j'ai commandé il ne pendra boxe
que voici
c'est juste magnifique j'ai décidé
d'essayer de l'ouvrir sur la chaîne en
temps réel mais le hasard a fait
qu'aujourd'hui à la maison il ya un pote
lui lui voilà les et bien ça que vous
avez déjà vu sur la chaîne monsieur
philippe roesch imitateur performeur
vocal humoriste mais surtout un pote et
mon cher philippe nous allons essayer
d'ouvrir sa ensemble sachant que c'est
une grosse difficulté la pandora box
mais il ya un moyen de l'ouvrir on a
juste besoin de nous trois je trouve ce
programme alléchant y en a pour un
moment base est parti premièrement on va
explorer la boîte un peu comme dans un
escape game on sait qu'une chose c'est
qu'on peut l'ouvrir c'est quoi la seule
chose qu'on a à savoir nous quand on
ouvre un casse tête c'est que il n'ya
pas besoin d'autre chose que de nos
doigts
voilà on sait que en l'état on doit être
capable de nouveau choisi la plus de
sucre but par la vidéo vers 6h20 comme
je vois plein de trucs comme ça je pense
il faut essayer de voir qu'est-ce qui
peut bouger
déjà quatre picot en accueillant sur le
4e temps voilà pas du tout je vais
connaît des créateurs de ce genre de
truc c'est à dire que souvent ils
mettent pleins de trucs en déco pour
nous perturber
daki voilà pour la fin c'est très gênant
il ya rien qui bouge en fait j'appuie la
sueur sur tous les trucs des quatre
côtés mais gare alors ça ça bouge un
petit peu mais je pense que l'ouverture
est là bien entendu y est bien c'est de
la smr écoute j'ai bien explorer je te
laisse voir qu'est-ce qui peut bouger
tous accepté l'accord en vrai c'est pas
la solution vraiment qu on ne finit pas
cette vidéo tampon n'a pas ouvert la
boîte à ça va être
à aucun moment ça peut partir contre le
mur non et nous revenir c'était pas
marqué de la notice on a quand même le
droit de faire avec les mains oui c'est
vrai donc si non mais tu as tu fait
partie du clan des ardeurs dicastère
je remercie d alors et en fait c'est le
genre de mec qui dort d'alain bihr ans
va prendre juste une pelleteuse et va
aller tout droit
bien qu'assez des ragots de bas quoi je
suis sorti les problèmes valeur pour
l'instant c'est comme toi mais donc il y
a écrit quelque chose dessus
non il n'ya pas de la marque de
l'ordinateur en fait c'est des trucs qui
sont vraiment fait en pièce unique n'est
pas industriel c'est tout fait à la main
ça ça bouge pas ça c'est impressionnant
j'avais envie d'appuyer dessus et ont
peut-être un tank avec le fond notation
des bulls d'un côté ou de l'autre des
deux des deux vous appuyez lui bouclé le
temps donnera le camp doha 12 cl
vraiment appuyé en le balo wenta on peut
l'enlever pas mal roche je peux pas dire
que je suis un génie et c'est alors là
pour l'instant d'aller c'est très très
beau donc là c'était retenu par un
aimant hi-fi ya un petit trou comme ça
et je pense à un bout de ferraille
est-ce qu'on peut le pousser ça s'est un
peu pas le pousser par contre moi j'ai
une idée
c'est à dire que si ça on a pu libérer
je pense que peu d'appuis en dessous ne
servait à rien d'ailleurs certains
alliés et je me dis si on a un aimant et
qu'on a ça ça veut dire que tu vois
à temps déjà on va chercher ce légume
est à lier je pense que tu viens de nous
faire gagner une heure à bas et puis
aussi je viens du gagner en temps de vie
parce que sinon ils auraient j'aurais
vraiment explosé d'accord donc moi je
tiens regarde prend le tu vas sentir en
fait que ça ça repousse
ah oui donc voilà c'est intéressant
alors ça je pense que c'est pas prévu au
programme
je pense que jeune déco l'élément de
l'intérieur s'est passé quelque chose
mesdames messieurs c'est à dire que
l'aimant a attiré la boule est allé qui
entraîne avec l'avenir la vis donc les
prodigieuses a par contre je pense
vraiment que j'ai fait de la merde et
qu'il fallait pas enfin je pense que ça
s'est décollé de ça et qu'il fallait pas
là quand l'om manière cumulative en
anglais toutes les vis d'accord on ne
vient pas elle vient donc on a deux
vices qui viennent sur les trois
questions
ok donc là on a toujours le pont de ré
avec le mans et on a ces deux vies cela
qu'ils m'ont l'air identique et qui a
prioris souvent comme ça c'est ce que
j'allais dire
[Musique]
je
et comme là ça tape dans le fond je
pense que si on a pu donc on est bien
d'accord puisque tu en train de dire
passe en accéléré
non pas du tout la jeune fille parce que
je pense que c'est un [ __ ] c'était ça
tu donnes moi j'ai vu j'ai vu j'ai vu le
moment où la soirée allait voilà on va
partir sur un apéro plus tôt est-ce que
sa part sur une ouverture de boîte ça
farcir une ouverture de boîte qui est
juste connu par les émaux comme ça
[ __ ] c'est pouces est battu mais ce
que tu veux là dedans
on a tué gala - de condom je sais pas et
je verrai ça déjà en termes de tournage
ça fait moins de dix minutes qu'on
tourne je crois que c'est vraiment parce
que ta ta ta ta ta trouvé cette bascule
moi j'ai eu peur aussi
après il ya passé une soirée y a pas
l'air d'avoir trente minutes chemin en
fait d'ouverture une fois classé en fait
et bien écoute je crois que tu t'ai
offert une nouvelle passion est-ce qu'on
verra cette photo de cette pandora box
sur ton instagram ben qu'armand s qui
ont désiré commenter la photo de
philippe hersant instagram vous avez son
instinct qui qui apparaît juste ici en
bas de nous vous pouvez vous pouvez le
rejoindre s'écroule clairement je
pensais qu'on a d'un bep pour 30 minutes
de tournage c'était quand même beaucoup
moins long oui il savait pas que j'étais
vous avez un cerveau extraordinaire
c'est que j'ai encore lu ton livre se
met à ce mec est bon je ne sais pas si
ça vous plaît comme ça les casse-têtes
sur la chaîne j'ai envie d'en faire de
plus en plus souvent
vous pouvez me le dira peut-être dans
les commentaires mais sur mon instagram
à moi aussi ça me ferait plaisir vous
l'avez qui s'affiche en bas lire dans la
description toi même tu sais hélas
philippe peut-être que tu te dis mais où
je peux trouver la pandora box mais où
je peux trouver la pandora box c'est une
bonne question jean-jacques écoute je
vous mets le lien dans la description
vers le site qu'il fabrique je crois
qu'il ya qu un seul site qui fabrique ça
n'hésitez pas à liker la vidéo à suivre
la chaîne
à très bientôt ciao
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]